recounting the terrifying moment his
yacht
snapped in two in rough seas off the
cape of good hope
he had just seconds to activate a
distressed beacon
and jump into a life raft the bar was
pointing uh
pointing to the to the sky it was
and when you see how fast the the water
comes inside the boat it's just amazing
i had only two minutes to
to to take whatever i had to take inside
and to go outside with my with my
survival suit
and to grab and to grab a life raft
the 40 year old was rescued after nearly
12 hours of drift by fellow frenchman
jean le cam who was the first of his
rivals to reach him
the vonde globe is a solo non-stop
round-the-world yacht race that takes
place
every four years it starts and finishes
at le sab dolo on france's atlantic
coast
and competitors must cover a distance of
twenty one thousand
six hundred and thirty eight miles
without touching land
the rescue happened some eight hundred
and forty nautical miles southwest of
cape town
the odds men will return to the
competition soon with time knocked off
for the rescue
and will no doubt hope that the rest of
the race proves to be less
dramatic ender brady sky news